et à présent les instructions pour le
sentimental sur laquelle on s'est mis
d'accord malachite et nous pourquoi ce
choix et bien parce que c'est le futur
un petit peu au présent m'enfin
temporelle dans les paroles dans la
musique c'est parti
[Musique]
m
oh la la la vie en rose
[Musique]
le rose qu'on propose
d'avoir les quantités de choses
qui donne envie d'autres jours
aïe on nous fait croire
[Musique]
que le bonheur c'est d'avoir
de l'avoir plein nos armoires
dérision de nous dérisoire
faut le sentimental
la soif d'idéal
[Musique]
attirés par les étoiles les voir que les
choses pas commercial
le sentimental
[Musique]
il faut voir comme on parle
comme on peut
il se dégage
ces cartons emballages
des gens avaient hors d'usagé
et triste et sans aucun avantage
on nous inflige
[Musique]
des désirs qui nous a plu
on nous prend faut pas déconner dès
qu'on est né pour des alors qu'une
foule sentimentale
soif d'idéal
attirés par les étoiles les voiles que
des choses pas commercial
pour le sentimental
il faut voir comment par
commente pas
[Musique]
on ou claudia schiffer
on nous parle hausse leader
ah le mal qu'on peut faire
et qui ava janin moquer
du ciel des vagues
un délit nos en bas
pour demain nos enfants par
[Musique]
un mur
je
peux sentir
pour les anti vandale
dans ce mois les a
attirés par les étoiles
que des choses pas commercial
pour le sentimental
il faut voir comment départ
comme en non pas
comme on nous parle
comme on peut
combes
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
dis-moi comment tu danses te dirai qui
tu es dis moi est ce que tu penses que
tout ça va durer toutes ces étoiles qui
dansent et qu'on laisse filer dis-moi
comment tu danses je te dirai qui tu es
dis-moi comment tu danses je te dirais
qui tu dis moi ce que tu penses que tout
ça va durer toute évidence et qu'on
laisse filer dis-moi comment tu danses
je te dirais qui tu
amitié scellée coeur les amis c'est ce
qui t'accompagne quand tu chantes eu
faux quand t'es pas hyper dussart ils
s'arrêtent pas les coeurs c'est
difficile de définir l'amitié et la
vraie quelque part c'est très simple
quelque part c'est très simple c'est
quand tu sait plus sur quel pied danser
tu sais plus où tu as tu allais quand la
vie va pas quand la vie va pas tu sait
plus sur quel pied danser tu sais plus
haute à talais ils s'arrêtent pas les
carnot il s'arrête pas dis-moi comment
tu danses te dirai qui tu es dis moi est
ce que tu penses que tout ça va durer
toutes ces étoiles qui dansent et qu'on
l'a ce fils qui moi comment tu danseurs
je te dirai qui tu es dis-moi comment tu
dans ce
je te dirai qui tu es tu mens est ce que
tu penses que tout ça va durer toutes
ces étoiles qui dansent et qu'on laisse
filer dis-moi comment tu danses je te
dirais qui tu
les amis c'est ceux qui sont encore là
point c'est ceux qui sont encore là
après toutes ces années après toutes les
distances après toutes les crises c'est
ceux qui sont encore là vraiment là et
malgré tout tu vois cette raison c'est
très simple c'est quand tu sait plus sur
quel pied a lancé tu sais plus où tu as
tu as tu allais quand la vie rapporte
quand la vie
tu sait plus sur quel quai a lancé tu
sais plus haut total et il savait carnot
il s'arrête
dis-moi comment tu danses je te dirais
qui tu dis moi ce que tu penses que tout
ça va durer
toutes ces étoiles qui dansent et qu'on
laisse filer dis-moi comment tu dans ce
te dire à qui tu dis moi comment tu
danses et je te dirai qui tu es dis moi
ce que tu penses que tout ça va durer
toutes ces étoiles qui dansaient et
qu'on a ce filet
dis-moi comment tu danses te dirais qui
tu dis moi comment tu danses
[Musique]
et moi comment tu danses
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
l'heure du bilan la cloche a sonné
dans le rétro tutoyer
nos rêves d'enfants nos choix de grands
la route de nom
c'est nier la
route de nos
[Musique]
il
s'en tire le calme après la compet
la brise la paye la fête
[Musique]
trop tard tant pis tempête s'est passé
n'a plus rien à
d
on n'a plus rien
[Musique]
oh
mais si on dit que c'est fini
il
demain
oui des anglaises
somadiaz
comment
quitter la voiture d'une autre c'est
pire
bien en cas plus fous
ça vaut pour autant des trois filets ne
pas sûr
r d
on n'a pas su à
[Musique]
perdre sa boussole et gary
considérant
[Musique]
le temps de ce mr et mme l
le temps pour mulhouse
ma vie
dans l'autre
[Musique]
si on dit
que ce fait ni
il y a
non
oui des enfants
[Musique]
au dépotoir des regrets
infinie
les artificielle paradis
tourner la tête vers le coeur léger
la carte qu'on voit c'est
oui
le sens qu'ils sont
sony
dakar qu on veut c
cher
elle sentit un sou
sonné
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]